My opponent tonight is
a former Rhodes Scholar,
the former mayor of Newark,
and the current senator
from New Jersey,
-Senator Cory Booker.
-It's good to see you.
-Good to see you, Jordan.
-Good to see you.
-Good to see you, too, Jordan.
-Welcome.
First I'd like to thank you
for coming.
I'd also like to thank Aiden
for letting us use
his room here.
BOOKER:
This is a pretty great room.
KLEPPER:
I'm a big fan of trains.
You know where you're going
with a train.
Yes, yes.
You got to stay on track in
life; it's a very good metaphor.
-Exactly.
-Yes.
-I want to stay on track, Cory.
-We've got some kids here.
-Yes.
There's a big march coming up.
Can you just,
can you just tell them
that this is a fad
and it's time to move on?
What do you think
about this march?
Well, two things.
One is, you have to understand
that change has never in history
come from Washington.
It's come to Washington.
Strom Thurmond
didn't just one day say,
"Hey, I think those black folks
should have some civil rights."
No. It was people that marched
and demonstrated
and brought change
to Washington.
What they're doing is not only
consistent with history,
it's actually been
the only pathway
that real, meaningful change
has been made
is through the activism
of young Americans.
And so you're supporting
these kids.
Have they,
have they bullied you?
Is that what I'm seeing
right now?
Are you gonna be
smoking some doobies
out by the park bench
with the cool kids?
I think that what these guys
are doing is leading by example.
They're letting adults know,
you guys haven't been able
to make change.
We have a horrific reality
where every day in America
dozens of people are dying
due to gun violence.
And that this has to stop.
You guys haven't stopped it,
so we're gonna take the helm
and lead the change.
Well, what-what's adults
problems?
I mean, I know I'm fine.
I got what I want.
Change not happening.
Status quo, thumbs up.
But you're an adult, you're an
adult in a position of power.
Why isn't change happening
from your end?
Well, first of all,
it's very frustrating.
I know what captures
a lot of attention
is often the mass shootings,
these awful, awful realities,
but every day in America,
we have lots of shootings
in communities like mine.
I've had two shootings
on my block in the last year.
Last-- most recently last week,
Shahad Smith was killed
by an automatic weapon at the
top of the block where I live.
I live in an inner city,
low-income community.
And so this is hurtful
that we have not been able
to make change.
And a lot of the times
the people in power
often don't represent the views,
Republican or Democrat,
of the majority
of their citizens.
And so this is the time
where the people want change.
They want common sense
gun safety measures to be done.
But the people in power
aren't doing anything.
And I think what these young
people are gonna show,
what the truth
in any democracy is,
that the power of the people
is greater than the people
in power.
You mentioned mass shootings.
And this movement seems to be
a response to school shootings,
but mass shootings
are only three percent
of the gun deaths
in America in 2017.
Is this a misguided movement?
Are they focusing
on the wrong things?
No, in fact, I've heard
incredible eloquence
by a lot of the young people
around the country,
young people from Parkland,
even young people in New Jersey,
who've been saying, "Hey, look,
we're gonna use this moment
"to shine a light on the fact
that we have,
"in many poor communities
and communities of color,
"that deaths are happening
every day,
and for some reason nobody
is paying attention."
Because again,
this is not a problem
that we can't
do something about.
We have the power
to make change.
And so what this is
a question of not is "can we,"
but "do we have
the collective will?"
And I think what they're doing
is waking up
the moral imagination
of this country,
uh, pointing
to the moral urgency,
and they're determined
to keep it going.
Now, you're talking a lot
about people coming together.
-Yeah.
-This is what you do.
You love to talk about that.
Wayne LaPierre talked about you
and your European socialism
when it comes to guns.
-Yes. -Do you just want
everybody to share one gun?
-Is that your ultimate vision
for America? -Um...
you know, when our founders
came together
and the end of
the Declaration of Independence
with these noble words that
if this country's gonna work,
we must mutually pledge
to each other, you know,
they said "our lives,
our fortunes,
and our sacred honor."
This is a country, yeah,
of rugged individualism,
and it's a country
of self-reliance,
but we also have proven
to humanity, you know,
rugged individualism
didn't get us to the Moon.
That when we come together
and work together and partner,
we can do things
that are beyond the imagination
-of our ancestors.
-(scoffs)
You really think
we went to the Moon?
(laughs)
I hate to do this
because this is my show,
but have I children here,
and apparently
they have questions.
So if you don't mind, there's
some questions they'd like...
You're giving over
some of your, uh...
-your platform, right.
-You know, I'm a nice guy.
Just because I'm an adult
and I think
we should talk down to children,
doesn't mean
I'm always going to talk down.
I was wondering
about this positioning.
You put them on the floor,
-Look, I... -and you had us
lord above the young people.
This is just functionally
the best position, all right?
-Okay.
-Don't let the metaphor play out
that I'm literally
talking down to children,
-Make you think that that's
what I want. -Uh, all right.
All right, well, even though
they're lower than us,
let's look up to them
and-and their stature.
So come on.
Mr. Booker, thank you
for talking to me today.
The Democratic party
has helped my movement
by giving us a platform,
and we've been speaking a lot
about change.
When will you actually propose
any change?
Right. Well, I'm hopeful
that this is gonna...
this election in November
is gonna be a referendum.
And I... I don't want it to be
a partisan election.
This is a...
simply about left or right,
or Republican or Democrat.
To me,
it's about right or wrong.
And if you are a person
standing up and blocking,
if you're in Congress right now
and you're blocking
what 90% of Americans want,
some of these
common-sense things,
then you need to be
voted out of office
because you are being complicit.
Our inaction is being complicit
in the continued violence.
My favorite question:
you've talked about a lot
of stuff I have no idea about,
and it really didn't stick.
So I'd like you to tell me
something I already know.
Well, I think you know
that the long arc of history
bends towards justice.
We are a country that's gotten
better and better and better,
-and you know that.
-Is that where it goes?
It does. It absolutely does.
But it doesn't bend
automatically.
We've got to be the benders.
And so the right side of history
right now
is finding the common ground
and doing those things
that will make America safer.
Yeah, I totally knew that.
-(laughs): All right.
-Senator Cory Booker.